día de altibajos en el seno de la unión
europea bruselas anunció hoy el cierre
del acuerdo para los presupuestos de los
próximos seis años y del plan de
recuperación para afrontar la crisis del
coronavirus que tiene previsto brindar
1,8 billones de euros a los socios
comunitarios el principal escollo eran
hungría y polonia pero sus jefes de
gobierno finalmente cedieron aunque las
cláusulas condicionales que obligan a
cumplir el estado de derecho para
obtener ayudas seguirán la comisión
europea no podrá imponer penalizaciones
hasta que haya una sentencia del
tribunal de justicia de la unión europea
me alegra que hayamos encontrado un
camino a seguir ahora que es importante
y que el mecanismo de condicionalidad no
ha cambiado
esto es crucial para mí y espero que
ahora podamos hacer avanzar el paquete
de 1.8 billones de euros porque los
ciudadanos europeos y las empresas lo
necesitan
otro asunto caliente para los líderes
europeos es definir el futuro de la
relación tras la salida del reino unido-
del bloque a la medianoche el 31 de
diciembre el primer ministro británico
boris johnson advirtió de la gran
posibilidad que existe de que no haya
acuerdo
tenemos que ser muy muy claros ahora hay
una gran posibilidad una gran
posibilidad de que tengamos una solución
que se parezca más a una relación
australiana con la unión europea que una
relación canadiense
los lazos entre reino unido y la unión
europea quedarían reducidos a los
acuerdos básicos de la organización
mundial del comercio
algo temido por las empresas que ya
están generando filas kilométricas en el
puerto de dover